[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de
l'actualité de la semaine à l'assemblée
et au sénat avec à mes côtés au
rayonnement cini bonjour orient a
gentiment et cette semaine notre invité
est françois grosdidier sénateurs les
républicains de la moselle bonjour à
vous bonjour et lundi alexandre benalla
était de retour au sénat auditionné par
la commission d' enquête sénatoriale les
sénateurs qui ont désormais terminé leur
audition mais face aux contradictions
des différents protagonistes
une question se pose désormais y at il
eu parjure la loi anti-casseurs examiné
en commission à l'assemblée nationale un
texte issu du sénat qui vise à réprimer
plus sévèrement les manifestants
violents mais les députés l'ont
considérablement remanié jugeant qu'elle
pouvait porter atteinte aux libertés
les sénateurs toujours aussi remonté
contre les 80 km/heure une composition
doit permettant d'en atténuer les effets
sur le permis à points était examinée
cette semaine le texte a certes été
rejetée mais les critiques contre les 80
km/heure n'ont pas manqué et cette
semaine alexandre benalla était donc de
retour au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour la deuxième fois à l'ancien chargé
de mission à l'elysée était auditionnée
par la commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
les sénateurs voulaient des explications
suite aux révélations sur ces passeports
diplomatiques
mais les auditions ont pris fin cette
semaine mais les questions sont encore
nombreuses quand un calme et six mois
dans kate et 34 audition au total en
juillet septembre et octobre dernier
puis à nouveau en janvier 2019 et malgré
toutes ces déclarations sous serment
beaucoup de questions restent encore
posé partie des violences de la place de
la contrescarpe la tentaculaire affaire
benalla a connu de multiples
rebondissements jusqu'à l'épisode des
passeports de l'ancien chargé de mission
à l'elysée
dévoilé par la presse cet hiver avec un
constat désormais par exemple sur la
question de ces passeports diplomatiques
les versions de l'église et est celle
d'alexandre benalla se contredisent
l'inventaire du bureau qui a été
effectué le 2 août confirme que les
passeports n'y était pas n'y était pas
on les mesures qui ont été prises et que
je viens de vous détailler et pour
lesquels il existe des notes de service
des courriers qui sont à votre
disposition permettent d'affirmer que
les passeports n'étaient pas à l'elysée
le 19 septembre lorsque j'étais présent
devant vous sous serment et que j'ai
répondu à l'ensemble des questions qui
m'ont été posées
je vous ai dit ils doivent être dans mon
bureau à l'elysée et ils ont dû les
restituer suisse may phrasé est complète
je vous réaffirme solennellement sous
serment encore une fois que le 19
septembre mais passeport était à
l'elysée pour jean pierre sueur et
muriel jourda les deux co rapporteurs
il est temps désormais d'écrire la
synthèse des travaux de la commission
avec une question essentielle avec ses
version qui diffère
y at il un parjure devant les sénateurs
d'abord
après dijon ce rapport présentons le et
ensuite nous déciderons effectivement de
ce qui convient de faire saisir le
parquet mme pas saisir le parquet mais
je conçois que ce soit quelque chose
assez important pour nos concitoyens
on donnera la réponse
en même temps que l'on présentera le
rapport des sénateurs qui espère
terminer et publié leur rapport au cours
du mois de février
alors françois grosdidier qu'avez vous
pensé de l'attitude d'alexandre benalla
durant cette seconde audition elle vous
a surprise où vous y attendiez
on s'y attendait parce que qu'est s'est
passé pendant quatre mois monsieur
benalla utilisés dont des faux
passeports et pour aller visiter des
chefs d'état étrangers
alors d'abord on nous a dit mais on
pouvait pas le savoir
après même sur le savait on pouvait pas
l'empêcher alors dans expliquant qu'il
avait pas le droit d utiliser
c'est assez surprenant mais on convoque
monsieur strzoda le directeur de cabinet
ainsi que deux ministres de l'intérieur
des affaires étrangères monsieur benalla
à peu près en même temps et l'elysée
portent plainte contre monsieur benalla
le mercredi la justice et d'une rapidité
extrême encore plus rapide que pour
fillon puisque le vendredi il est
convoqué par le juge ce qui permet
permet de le placer sous statut de
témoin assisté pour qu'il ne puisse plus
témoignant en tout cas s'abrite derrière
ce statut pour ne plus témoigner le
lundi donc c'était tout de même
extraordinaire comme célérité pour lui
permettre de ne pas parler devant une
autre commission dit clairement qu'il
n'y a pas de hasard
non j'ai pas possible on avait un dans
ce sujet un des contradictions entre
alexandre benalla entre patrick strzoda
qui représente l elysée s qu'à l'issue
de ces auditions et peut-être avec un
petit peu plus de recul
les joueurs ayant passé vous sentez
clairement qu'ils vous ont menti et si
oui qui vous a menti j'ai pris beaucoup
de monde
il n'y a pas que monsieur ben alors déjà
sur les passeports forcément où monsieur
strzoda où monsieur benalla de façon
factuelle
l'un des deux a menti mais on nous ment
depuis départ même secrétaire général de
la présidence même
directeur de cabinet le chef de cabinet
on nous dit qu au départ monsieur
benalla s'occupe de tout sauf de
sécurité protocole organisation des
déplacements
et puis après comme il est toujours four
à la préfecture de police à odos dit non
mais faut forcément qui coordonne tous y
compris la sécurité puis quand on
découvre qu'il a une autorisation de
port d'armes
maudit le directeur de cabinet nous dit
oui mais vous comprenez c'est pour
renforcer la sécurité du président dans
les déplacements privés incohérent avec
le j'espère le groupe de protection de
la faune au public qui nous assure qu'il
le couvre en permanence
et puis monsieur bénin est lui-même non
non j'ai demandé un port d'armes pas
pour protéger le président mais pour me
protéger moi parce que je suis moi même
menacé comme si le monsieur benalla qui
accompagne tout temps de présenter
lui-même une cible pouvant exposer le
président à d'éventuels balles perdues
quoi c'est complètement incohérent
comme sur la sphère des passeports ou le
miz affaires étrangères nous déclare
avoir découvert le 26 décembre seulement
que monsieur pénale avait vu le 12
décembre le président tchadien alors que
le président de la république française
lui même boyer le président tchadien le
22 et que l'ambassadeur de france à
djamena avait oublié de prévenir paris
quoi on est sur des invraisemblances de
bout en bout dans cette affaire lors que
ça aurait été tellement simple de nous
expliquer qu en fait monsieur benalla
été vu avec le staff de campagne lui
étant chargé la sécurité même s'ils un
peu plus 7 6 1 quelqu'un qui a un sens
politique et une capacité d analyse qui
faisaient plus qu'un garde du corps et
certainement aussi un conseiller bas
nous dire que ça entre choqué avec les
services un moment pics été recadré et
et puis pour le sénat on en aurait
conclu qu'il y avait eu un
dysfonctionnement et que les choses
étaient recadra on aurait préconisé d un
certain nombre de mesures pour que ça se
reproduise plus et que la sécurité reste
aux forces de sécurité intérieure pour
voilà ça aurait été tellement simple de
ne pas mentir alors qu'à partir d'un
petit dysfonctionnement des temps on a
construit un mensonge des temps mais
mentir devant une commission d enquête
ce n'est pas rien pour vous clairement
il ya eu par joueur c'est pas rien il ya
eu parjure alors au minimum de monsieur
vialade monsieur strzoda façon factuelle
mais après on a eu ces vérités qui sont
alors est-ce qu'on peut poursuivre ou
pas ces vérités glissante qui n'ont
cessé de l'a22 déplacer entre le pas de
sécurité du tout et puis la coordination
de la sécurité puis finalement peu de
sécurité
effectivement est ce qu'on peut
qualifier judiciairement verra alors au
delà des passeports alexandre benalla
refusé de répondre sur la nature de ses
activités depuis son départ de l'elysée
il n'y a pas un risque de conflit
d'intérêts comment s'assurer qu'il n'a
pas tiré parti d'informations ou de
contact établi alors qu'il travaillait
pour le président on peut nullement sont
assurées peut effectivement nullement
s'en assurer parce que effectivement à
l'elysée il n'y a pas plus d'ailleurs
qui avait oublié de faire les
déclarations auprès de la haute autorité
pas transparence de la vie au public
tous les parlementaires ils sont
astreints à l'elysée manifestement tout
le monde en ce sens était complètement
exonérés lors de la première audition là
qu en est il exactement et puis quand
monsieur benalla se déplace à l'étranger
va-t-il y livrer des informations ce
fonctionnement de l'alizé de l'elysée au
détriment des intérêts français où
va-t-il
au contraire servir les intérêts
français il semblerait qu'il ait
continué à conseiller le président
utilement en décembre à la fois sur les
conditions d'emploi des forces mobiles
qui étaient trop statiques lors des
manifestations ou donnant des
informations utiles sur le tchad avant
la visite du président de la république
et des informations que d'assez de
l'afrique n'aurait pas donné
donc c'est pas forcément inutile mais on
sait pas exactement ce qui fait qu'elle
est son rôle
et pour moi les centrales à dessert les
intérêts des enfants vous alexandre
bédat n'a été couvert par l'elysée et
couple est toujours derrière par
l'elysée
manille manifestement c'est pas possible
que l'on soit dans l invraisemblance et
qu'ils puissent utiliser passeport
diplomatique pendant quatre mois
le ministre de l'intérieur nous explique
y avait aucun fondement juridique pour
empêcher alors qu'il avait plu droit d
utiliser surprenant le ministre des
affaires étrangères une heure après nous
explique que c'est pour des raisons
techniques
tout tout tout tout ce tout ça et puis
après on nous déclare qu on ne savait
même pas qu'il était au tchad des jours
avant de pleinement république doit
cesser or quand monsieur griveaux dit
que c'est pas de bureau des légendes
c'est pas dur des légendes c'est
vraiment les pieds nickelés on n'imagine
pas à de tels dysfonctionnements de
l'état à ce niveau et au tchad ou où nos
troupes sont engagés
et où nous sommes totalement impliqué
dans la lutte contre terrorisme quoi
tout ça paraît complètement surréaliste
on va passer à un autre tag main la loi
anti-casseurs examinée à cette semaine
en commission à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
annoncé début janvier par edouard
philippe cette loi anti casseurs étaient
est examiné en commission à l'assemblée
nationale pour aller plus vite le
gouvernement a choisi de s'appuyer sur
une loi des républicains déjà votée par
le sénat en fin d'année dernière
problème elle est trop dure pour une
partie de la majorité l'exercice de
réécriture et donc périlleux résumé des
débats signé mari la bat
avant même son arrivée en commission le
texte suscite et déjà l'embarras voulue
par edouard philippe mais issu d'un
travail législatif de la droite
sénatoriale
la proposition de loi anti casseurs se
heurtent des l'article 1er sur les
périmètres de sécurité aux abords des
manifestations aux tâtonnements de la
majorité cet article 1 ne paraît pas
juridiquement stabiliser en termes de
déquilibre constitutionnel dans sa
rédaction actuelle c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je propose la suppression
de cet article 1 avec une proposition
qui nous est faite par le gouvernement
de nous proposer une nouvelle rédaction
d'ici la séance la gauche comme la
droite saisissent alors l'occasion pour
pointer du doigt l'amateurisme de la
majorité je connaissais la vente à la
découpe
je découvre le texte à la découpe voilà
c'est ce texte va être complètement
démantelée quel signal vous voulez
donnez vous l'expliquer que vous
reprenez un texte de la droite pour
apparaître sécurité pour apparaître
ayant de la fermeté pour ensuite revenir
en arrière et met des contreparties
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire à
l'article 2 sur l'interdiction
administrative de manifester pour les
casseurs c'est au sein même de la
république en marche que les
dispositions sont contestés je crois que
cette rédaction introduit une dose
d'arbitraire trop grande dans une
décision qui
fait a trait à nos libertés
individuelles la liberté de manifester
qui est une liberté clé dans notre
démocratie contre pouvoirs nécessaires
l'article sera finalement voté après
suppression de l'article 5 punissant le
port d'armes en manifestation les six
autres articles ont été adoptés
le texte sera examiné mardi prochain en
séance publique
françois grosdidier les députés en
commission largement modifié la version
du sénat est ce que vous le regrettez
bien sûr parce que bon d'abord j'étais
un peu compte en me disant enfin la
démocratie parlementaire refonctionne 1
de cette crise qui est d'abord apparu
parce qu'il ya plus de démocratie
sociale plus de démocratie locale qui
étouffe et et la butte démocratie
parlementaire puisque l'exécutif décide
de tout détient là on va pour une fois
reprend d'une initiative parlementaire
bon alors hélas j'ai découvert là que
quand je découvre pas d'un confirmation
que la majorité des députés de la
république en mars sont issus de la
gauche lors des ans un socialiste
converti au libéralisme économique mais
mais restant incurablement laxistes en
matière de sécurité est donc là
effectivement il démantèle waouh c'est
pour redonner la malle exécutif donc à
nouveau et a puni sciatique
parlementaires parce qu'on dit qu'on
abroge d'un article
on a mende pas on le remplace pas on
attend que le gouvernement rédige un
nouveau un peu surprenant pour un débat
mais le mans et 200 points restent dans
le texte est bien évidemment votre
autrement de textos rien
comment vous voulez contrôler un accès
s'il n'y a pas un périmètre délimité le
problème il s'agit d'appliquer aux
manifs ce qui marche contre le
hooliganisme
c'est à dire que ceux qui ont déjà
commis des exactions ou ceux qui ont
déjà été condamnées ou répertorié comme
ou appelant à aller commettre puisse
être interdits de manifestation comme on
peut interdire les hooligans de stade
bon dans l'estadio nemisz physique dans
les manifestations si on fixe pas un
périmètre il n'a pas donc on peut pas
les empêcher d'y aller donc si vous
enlevez les périmètres c'est plus la
peine d'adopter cette loi donc cesser ce
qui est aberrant donc que vous entendez
une partie des députés de la majorité
dire que cette loi peut être liberticide
car elle contreviendrait peut-être à la
liberté de venir en quoi elles sont pas
fondées et s'aider d'un qu'on a eue au
sénat en quoi est-ce liberticide
d'empêcher non pas des manifestants mais
d'empêcher des cas répertoriés de
s'introduire dans les manifestations
c'est au contraire protéger la liberté
de manifestation que de protéger les
manifestations de ces casseurs comme on
a protégé le sport en empêchant les
hooligans et bien de rentrer dans les
stades vous ne venait pas pour le sport
mais mais pour pour vandaliser pour
casser pour insulter et bien il s'agit
d'appliquer la même chose de
manifestations puisque ça marchait pour
le sport donc et si on n'a pas des
périmètres de sécurité
s'il est pas possible d'interdire eh
bien ça ne fonctionnera pas ne faut pas
faire croire aux forces de l'ordre ou à
l'opinion qu'on adopte une mesure pour
ne plus que se reproduise ce qui s'est
produit lors des manifs et gilet jaune
mais ce qui existait avant c'est pour ça
que c'était pas d'ailleurs lio gilet
jaune
nous on l'a proposé après notre dame des
landes est les manif du 1er mai parce
que depuis plusieurs années de façon
récurrente des extrémistes de droite ou
de gauche ou des casseurs ou des voyous
droit commun s'introduisent dans les
manifestations pour pour les dévoyer les
détourner et si on n'adopte pas le texte
du sénat qui peut être amendée à la
marge mais pas haut mais pas vidé de sa
substance comme vient de le faire
l'assemblée nationale alors cette
semaine c'est la question des 80
kilomètres heure qui a fait débat au
sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au moment où emmanuel macron a ouvert la
porte à une adaptation de la mesure le
sénat examiner une proposition de loi
centriste visant à accélérer la
récupération de points en cas de petit
excès de vitesse le texte a été rejeté
par le sénat mais les sénateurs ont
vivement critiqué les 80 km/heure
mesures imposées aux territoires ruraux
béatrice faisant réduire de six à trois
mois le délai nécessaire pour récupérer
un point sur le permis de conduire une
idée dangereuse pour le rapporteur
breton qui a tiré le signal d'alarmé
il existe en effet un risque important
que les conducteurs certain de récupérer
leurs points plus rapidement adoptent
des comportements à risque six mois
il ya déjà une durée courte si nous la
réduisons nous risquons de nuire à la
vertu pédagogique du permis à points et
à son efficacité en matière de lutte
contre les infractions routières
mercredi le sénat examiner la
proposition de loi relative à
l'aménagement du permis à points une
proposition déposée par la sénatrice de
l'ain en contrepartie de l'abaissement à
80 km/heure de la vitesse sur les routes
secondaires très impopulaire je ne fais
pas ça à titre personnel puisque on m'a
soufflé tu fais ça parce que tu n'as pas
lu plus de points j'ai encore douze
points chers amis je n'ai encore pas
fait de stage que le sénat envoie un
signal fort aux français c'est notre
rôle que de défendre les territoires et
que de défendre ses habitants jour merci
mais pour la république en marche
l'argument n'est pas valable
je ne crois pas que la
déresponsabilisation des conducteurs
soit l'objectif recherché par cette ppl
notre objectif commun est bien de
trouver un juste équilibre entre la
lutte concrète contre l'insécurité
routière et l'adoption de mesures qui ne
soit pas ressenti comme injuste par nos
concitoyens
et selon le sénateur le grand débat
national sera justement l'occasion de
soulever cette question des 80 km heure
mais pour les sénateurs républicains les
français ont déjà tranché après de vifs
débats
de chaque côté de l'hémicycle être c'est
l'heure du vote pour l'adoption 86
contre 255 le sénat n'a pas adopté
et le résultat est largement contre
françois grosdidier les sénateurs
s'opposent depuis longtemps à la mise en
place de ces 80 km heure en tout cas à
la manière dont ils ont été mises en
place et pourtant ce texte a été rejeté
la droite notamment voté contre
pourquoi parce que nous sommes
responsables et contrairement à ce que
raconte le gouvernement sur les 80 nous
ne sommes pas des démagogues prêt à
sacrifier la sécurité routière nous
avons parfaitement conscience que grâce
à des mesures compris d'ailleurs
gouvernement que nous soutenions est
bien là la mortalité sur les routes a
été divisé par quatre et que ces
dernières années elle progresse tout
doucement donc il s'agit d'arrêter il
s'agit de savoir comment donc
certainement pas en déresponsabiliser
reste déresponsabilisant des
automobilistes mais quel est le problème
sur ces 80 et et ça élargit d'ailleurs
la question à la gouvernance de la
france en pleine crise des gilet jaune
c'est que tout est décidé d'en haut
le problème c'est que on est dans une
situation aujourd'hui où on était plutôt
dans une situation où un département
n'avait pas le droit de limiter à 80
km/heure parce que l'état avait décidé
que c'était 90 donc même dans des routes
un peu sinueuse dangereuse des routes
accidentogènes
c'était aux 90 ou 70 ce qui est absurde
bon et de l'état prête prétend
effectivement déterminer la limitation
d'absolument tout les routes même du
réseau secondaire en france qui n'existe
dans aucun autre pays européen
qu'est ce qu'on dit nous simplement mais
qu'on laisse les présidents de conseils
départementaux pour les routes
départementales en concertation avec le
préfet et la gendarmerie départementale
déterminer quelle doit être la
limitation c'est aussi bête que ça
et ça le gouvernement le refuse alors
emmanuel macron a ouvert la porte quand
même sur ce point que vous a entendu et
pourquoi parce qu'il se rend compte que
ça pète simplement qu' on en peut plus
d'un système où la démocratie c'est
transformant technocratie où le
parlement ne joue pas pleinement ce rôle
non pas parce que les parlementaires
sont mauvais on parle de crise la
démocratie représentative houdini dit
d'inutilité des représentants mais ils
sont inutiles quand ils sont pas écoutés
c'est pas que les représentants sont
mauvais c'est que le sommet ne les
écoute pas est ce que m
c'est aussi les reprenne les dons est
écouté par le sommet et donc on a une
assemblée par une assemblée nationale
qui est aux ordres j'ai été député c'est
ce que c'est quand même la discipline de
vote on est beaucoup plus libre au sénat
et ce phénomène s'est encore renforcé
ces 18 derniers mois on a un sénat qui
est libre mais qui est beaucoup moins
écouté alors il est seulement maintenant
sur les 80 kilomètres/heure alors sur la
loi anti casseurs on verra on l'avait
dit aussi mais on avait aussi dit
attention danger si on a en même temps
l'envolée des cours du pétrole et la
trajectoire carbone on n'a pas été
écouté le président est revenu dessus
posteriori il aurait été bien inspiré
d'écouter le sénat et ses 2 des
sénateurs les plus écolos vont elles
l'abbé jean françois husson qui avait
mis en garde le gouvernement qui avait
rien voulu entendre en dix ans les taxes
les taxes indirectes sont indolores on a
vu comme elle l'était c'est
effectivement ce qu'on n'a pas en cours
de finance publique c'est le dogme de
bercy mais c'est pas la réalité du
ressenti des français donc donc est ce
que pour vous la mise en place de ces 80
km h ça a été peut-être un élément
déclencheur dans la colère du pays on
n'en serait pas là si vous avez écouté
plus tôt enfin je vous dis tu sais les
décisions dans aux prises partout et
pour tout le monde ces technocrates qui
pensent tout savoir tout connaître mieux
que les corps intermédiaires mieux que
les élus locaux ccl il n'ya pas
démocratie parlementaire la démocratie
locale a été de plus en plus corsetée à
la fois par la réglementation et par la
baisse des moyens et la démocratie
sociale ne fonctionne pas suffisamment
dans notre pays
alors l'on n'attend pas du président de
la république dans une forme de
césarisme technocratique simplement
qu'ils renouent avec le peuple et décide
de tout y compris de la façon dont elle
n'a cueilli dans une administration de
la sécurité sociale ou non on attend
qu'ils remettent en marche la démocratie
parlementaire la démocratie sociale la
démocratie locale et à ce moment là on
aura résolu une grande partie de la
crise démocratique qui se pose alors
justement jeudi soir emmanuel macron cet
invité un débat citoyen est ce que vous
saluer le fait est qu'ils dialoguent
directement avec les français peut-être
plus non seulement avec les maires et
tant mieux qu'ils découvrent le peuple
non mais j'en suis content parce que
et on avait jusqu'à présent des
présidents qui connaissait le peuple
mais dont la technostructure
progressivement les isoler à l'elysée là
on a eu pour la première fois un
président qui n'a lui même pas coutume
le peuple bon c'est pas son parcours il
n'a jamais été élu
il a baigné dans des milieux favorisés
si tout d'un coup ils le découvrent
ce qu'il faut c'est que ce soit durable
c'est que ce soit pas un coup de
marketing comme l'était la grande marche
simplement pour sortir de la crise et
que derrière on reparte sur ce
fonctionnement démocratique sur ce
fonctionnement technocratique
il faut remettre en marche cette
démocratie représentative parlementaire
social local on peut introduire un peu
de démocratie directe avec le rythme et
on peut pas faire un référendum par
semaine pour se substituer mocratie
parlementaire il propres responsabilités
premières président de république c'est
de garantir les institutions et de les
remettre en fonctionnement pour ne pas
dire en marche
allez on en vient notre dernier thème
cette loi pour les élèves en situation
de handicap
examiné à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une loi adoptée en commission c'était
mercredi une surprise bien que le sujet
puisse sembler consensuelle car le texte
ne vient pas de la république en marche
mais du groupe socialiste une précédente
proposition de loi similaire présenté
par les républicains avait d'ailleurs
été rejetées l'an dernier suscitant des
réactions outrées cette fois la majorité
semble décidé à changer de méthode
elle a voté le texte mais dans une
version largement remaniée rabique à
tout avait pourtant bien commencé
contrairement au texte proposé quatre
mois plus tôt par les républicains
la majorité n'a cette fois pas déposer
de motion de rejet préalable
j'observe madame la députée chers
collègues que votre ton collectif a
changé c'est heureux il aura fallu pour
cela une proposition de loi des
républicains balayé de manière honteuse
pourtant quelques minutes plus tard le
constat n'est plus le même la majorité
vient de rejeter les deux premiers
articles et je voudrais bien comprendre
puisque d'entrée de jeu on nous a dit
nous acceptons de débattre de votre
texte c'est la moindre des choses
et heureusement qu'il ya pas de motion
de procédure en commission mais depuis
l'article 1 a été refusée l'article 2 a
été refusé ce sont les deux articles de
mon point de vue le coeur de la
proposition de loi
l'article 1 garantie l'attribution
d'accompagnement scolaire pour les
élèves handicapés au plus tard le 45e
jours précédant la rentrée scolaire
l'article de lui vise à mettre fin à la
précarité des accompagnants scolaires en
les recrutant en cdi dès le premier
contrat mais la majorité n'a pas rejeté
tous les articles puisque cinq sur neuf
ont été votés parmi eux
l'article 7 il vise à faciliter l'accès
aux établissements scolaires pour les
élèves handicapés
autre proposition votée établir des
statistiques plus précises sur la
situation et les besoins des personnes
en situation de handicap en trois heures
de débat la majorité n'a déposé aucun
amendement qui est pour l'adoption de
cette proposition de loi qui est contre
et donc adopté à l'unanimité
elle sera donc débattu dans l'hémicycle
le 31 janvier prochain
françois grosdidier sur la méthode
d'abord le gouvernement avait rejeté
quasiment toutes les propositions
lois venues de l'opposition jusqu'ici
cette semaine il a voté trois venue du
groupe socialiste vous voyez un signe
d'ouverture des contenants mi-politique
voix mais c'est exactement ce que je
venais de vous dire cette conversion
tout d'un coup tu démocratique du pays
d'un président une majorité qui
accepteraient désormais que la
démocratie parlementaire fonctionne
comme dans les autres grands pays
démocratiques
il faut pas que ce soit simplement pour
donner le change et faire semblant et là
on a l'impression d'un deux cas une loi
une loi socialiste effectivement sur sur
l'intégration des enfants handicapés en
milieu scolaire qui reprend quasiment
les termes d'une proposition doit l'air
qui elle avait été rejetée
et puis on a cette proposition de loi
anti casseurs qui vient du sénat dans
les deux cas le gouvernement immense
progrès dit ok on accepte d'en débattre
au lieu de rejeter par une motion de
procédure l'initiative ppte oriane parce
que jusqu'à présent tout ce qui venait
pas du gouvernement étaient rejetés
d'emblée sauf parfois une proposition de
loi mais venant exclusivement du groupe
majoritaire c'était le cas pour la loi
sur la compétence eau assainissement et
bien là il accepte mais ils font
semblant puisqu'il accepte mais après
rejette directement les articles les
plus substantielles et en faisant
confiance au gouvernement pour les
réécrire donc alors ils ont fait un
quart de l'exercice on attend le typha
les trois quarts du chemin et après on
pourra se dire que le président le
gouvernement et la majorité sont
sincèrement persuadé qu'il faut remettre
en marche la démocratie parlementaire
comme la démocratie représentative d'une
façon générale mais ça c'est le mot de
la fin merci fonceur 10 d'avoir été
cette semaine avec no mercy thibault on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle semaine d'actualité
parlementaire
[Musique]